this is the mountain so much to say
about this one just a mountain full if
you will you know you ever watch like
that weird movie when you're a little
kid that's like really trippy and makes
no sense and you just can't watch it
like this that was kind of my experience
with this but it's lemongrab and his
kingdom treating his people a bit better
I guess they still had to carry him form
a long line and carry him to his bed but
you know he's not like beating them I
guess
and he looks on his ceiling and there
was like this mural that has like this I
don't know how to move on to the nest
next existential plane or something like
that
and he just decides he wants to go there
like the it starts to crack a little bit
like the head of one of them starts to
crack and like a little worm or
something comes out so he goes to go on
this journey on the mountain Finn sees
Flame Princess wants to get distracted
so he goes and follows him and they
entered this trippy Mountain where you
can kind of choose one of these three
paths if you choose the right one that
takes you to like the center which is
called Matthew and Lemongrab is looking
to join with him for I'm not gonna lie I
blanked out what was gonna happen if you
joined with him I was already like just
so so what was it it basically Matthew
or the mountain of Matthew it's where
beings and people come to become like
bait boiled down to their base existence
and become part of him so therefore when
ii was the second terror comes he'll be
whole so when the was the first terror
like the stitcher did you say to this
day i know i like i just said like the
past couple ones i got it right Oh
but God I'll get it they can look at my
butt my butt look at that but we met but
yeah
sure he's adorable look at that he only
just got this in the mail today and yeah
I can see why you got that because that
to me sorry go on
no of eyeballs the first terror do okay
I was making sure that wasn't my did in
this so you know Lemongrab so so I try
even remember now so that's kind of like
no this doesn't sound right or I guess I
miss you but no lemon crab know what she
throws the little lemon drops or
whatever in Joan's lemonjon's to my brew
lemon John was okay the giant it's been
a whole week man I know it's been a week
the whole the basic his giant castle was
a giant lemon being okay who pretty much
committed suicide and turned into a
whole bunch of basically lemon heads
okay so they're called lemon jumps now
because his name was lemonjon so he
threw the lemons in him okay and that
turned into just a bunch of other little
lemon grads know what happened okay so
since lemon John was pretty much made
kind of from Lemongrab lemonjon's would
be him so if he's being boiled down to
his base elements but he's still there
what's gonna happen I don't know but
they weren't him those were other people
that went there to become part of
Matthew they don't looked alike though
didn't they yeah they were all boiled
down so okay so they got free yeah but
didn't want to be free so he just
screwed everything up kind of yeah and
they just went back home yeah she's done
now he's done now
and he just crashed into his bed and
then just saw the little hole on the
ceiling took some of the goo and just
threw it out in there and that was the
mountain
how am I supposed to say about this I
had no idea what to say about this it
was chippy Alex I always liked some of
those you know what am I looking for
I don't want to say booby traps but like
those choices you can make where it's
like which one do you choose I always
kind of like stories that have that you
must choose one of these three um with
it I think it was only two was there
that did they have it on the floor no
was the butterfly oh that's where as the
butterfly that's right
and and they you choose they both choose
they both choose a third one so they
choose you know the right one and yeah
you know I can't like the old mentality
of going to a mountain especially ones
they're gonna do like weird yeah happy
put it bogus won't guess hocus-pocus was
it again just go with that yeah okay
I'll go with that um you know that kind
of stuff you know weird haunted stuff
and you had to make choices you have to
do that you of course are the India
Joneses stuff um and so I like oh man I
like the truthiness but I have no idea
what this was about but it I just know
it was surreal a night I love surreal
stuff um but I don't know what I'm gonna
take from it how about you um well for
one I'm guessing and I'm curious I I
don't honestly know if the mountain of
Matthew is a reference to the mountains
of madness from HP Lovecraft which I'm
kind of cuz that's yeah so that's one
thing uh - for me it's more or less it's
the search for yourself
it's if you boil boil yourself down to
like just the basic you can you still be
something else or are you stuck in that
path and I think that's kind of what
Lemongrab was looking for I guess but
does he
what kind of comes of it though I mean
Jesse messes up these other guys that
wanted to be melted down and now they're
not dead is it that there's just nothing
to him I mean that he is just kind of
this he's looking at himself and that's
it there's nothing deeper died because
you did kind of see you like there are
these other weird temptations and stuff
yeah good luck bubblegum
the catcher's mitt or the bass moment if
the other mitt plays yeah what le he
goes to sleep they put him in on down
I'm just like why remember last week
there was the room like they were going
through the his castle his kingdom and
there were a bunch of rooms with nothing
but a mitt in each room mm-hmm
we never figured out what that yeah only
see well that he just wants to play
catch with the mitt yeah or maybe
Peebles played catch with him when he
was young
oh that's true yeah cuz they have that
long can it you know that very well
could be yeah he wants to return like
maybe something of the past or you know
thing that could it's like the three
choices for each one was kind of like
the thing they're longing for the most
the thing they're afraid of to an extent
and kind of like a more like this the
third option is kind of like beyond the
other two well and the the first one
especially seemed both the with the
first - it seemed like here's something
that you really wanted from the path so
even though Flame Princess is like still
doing her exercises or whatever it's
still something that you know he was
close to having in the past yeah you
know and then with Lemongrab you know
doing that activity with sang from the
past and then with the new ruler loving
grams yeah lemonhope there you know
that's something that I'm assuming is
more like either happening now where
it's going to be happening well that
would be the future
yeah the future and then the same thing
with Finn like they're making the Finn
cakes it's like oh my Finn cakes you
know like that'll be something in the
future so like yeah there is definitely
like something from the past and from
the future and that like you said it's a
good way point just something beyond
them yeah it's not an earthly thing it's
not a normal something too long for like
Lemongrab actually was like no no don't
hurt him almost like he's feeling
something beyond himself yeah and of
course Finn was just being Finn but I
love the whole them being on themselves
being on themselves kind of like that an
infinite loop if you will I thought that
was kind of cool again that whole thing
of do we live one I've guessed
do we live okay I love men in black are
we just in a marble you know being
played marbles with was that where our
galaxy is and all that stuff and it's
kind of almost what that is are you just
on yourself to an extent
hmm just look at yourself look at
yourself I mean how far can you look
into yourself before you finally get to
that point where nothing changes yeah I
can't you know you see a lot of those
like like I'll say the mirror looking
into the mirror like you said men in
black and the marble and stuff and
that's kind of an interesting to you
being a speck on yourself is kind of a
fun you know infinite reality kind of
thing just have a fun idea but yeah
anything else you just took from it cuz
I have my job yeah I to me I think that
it shows Lemongrab has grown up in a
sense like he's everything's being
productive Nellie things are actually
getting yeah and they're making stuff
and it's like even this sort of journey
he like he's choosing to do with the
kind of further himself whether or not
it worked or even had that big an impact
on him you know it's like he's he's
making the effort you're right he is
kind of evolving even if it is like just
a tiny bit yeah or maybe even a lot by
his standards who knows I mean remember
last time for the most part he was
already eating like his brother yeah I
mean really really bad yeah and now it's
like he's feeding everyone they're
actually doing things to being
productive you know yeah they are of
course carrying him to bed but I mean I
do that all the time with jewelry um but
no like to me it's like a show of growth
you know they're yeah they're all doing
something productive instead of just
kind of running around like idiots to an
extent and lemongrab wanting to can like
figure out more it's like huh I wonder
what else is going on to an extent is
showing growth but yeah in the end it's
kind of like it's not like a philosopher
that's like oh I'll learn something I'm
gonna write about it until the world
lemongrab doesn't need to and doesn't
care too
he learned it that's all he needed to
learn and he's done it just goes back to
bed and fit actually I think I finally
get the crack yeah oh yeah I'm just
realizing cuz it's like you know it's
almost like there's something missing in
himself is like a crack and then when he
gets back he fixes it like you know I
fix that but you mix it with the stuff
II was here the lemon gem site yeah Oh
better than my sperm analogy you look so
much better on these V logs right now
that I am I'm not gonna lie usually I'm
like you know talking about all this
stuff and you're sort of saying to to
I'm just like well do it's weird is
pretty you're coming up with like these
really cool and allergies I'm like oh my
god write a book like you can write a
book on these things so uh know that
that helped me up you're you're a good
teacher you're not getting a gold star
do the truffle shuffle